I got my eyes and shut my eyes my name
is Andrew I'm the father of a beautiful
eight-year-old named Lin fatherhood has
been an amazing journey it definitely
changed my perspective on how I view
things I've been co-parenting with my
daughter's mom for the last three years
what that means is originally it was a
50/50 split and now that I moved to
California kind of been only weekends
but to kind of offset the time the
animals here as much as I used to we try
to make the weekends really fun and over
pet it's been a journey and it's been a
learning experience for both of us to be
honest I'm excited because I'm always
going to Phoenix this is her first time
coming out to LA she's getting older now
she's about to start there great so I
wanted to give her the opportunity to
decide what we do this weekend little
bit how you doing yeah do you miss me
over like a lot or a little bit a little
bit a lot she's just messed up what do
you want to do when you get here we
should do something fun like you want to
buy some clothes and stuff I'm not a
makeup fan and I'm not saying I'm anti
makeup I just don't understand it
I thought I had a little bit more time
where she was like let's build a unicorn
house buy me some like Barbie playhouses
growing up my dad was the dad's dad
watched news all day talked about cars
sports things like that so anything
makeup makeover is just that's my mom's
Lane that's my sister's Lane he never
talked abouts things like that so when
she called me asking about makeup it was
100% out of my wheelhouse I felt a
little nervous about it but I'm gonna
figure something out I'm a figure it out
thinking through YouTube
it's not looking good there's so many
videos I have a whole new respect for
morning routines like women you guys are
truly amazing tough to worry about
contouring there's not a thing anymore
so a lot of my friends were out of their
element as well so I figured I need a
guru to really help me figure this all
out
all right time to exit the guru to help
me out right now
we got Freddie say was that - I was very
nervous asking Freddie from ladylike for
help just because I was a little bit
intimidated because ladylike is so good
at makeup they do challenges they make
it hard for them to do makeup baby
that's coming in this weekend she wants
to get a complete makeover she said eyes
lips cheeks I don't know what that means
okay do you have a photo of area yes
what do you think extra do yes okay
she's so cute
thank you I appreciate that so one thing
that I did appreciate her going so in
debt she and I are similar complexion so
for me when I go for a blush tone I go
for something a little bit deeper like a
berry now she said she said the process
so I would try to find a palette that
has a nice mix of browns and neutral
tones and also warm tones when you do
her eye shadow
the biggest tip that I can give you is
making sure that you blend properly it
was a little hard for me to keep up I'll
be honest so if you're using more than a
little color on her eye on her eyelid
make sure you blend the two after you
use more than one color you don't have
to okay it's like a gradient yeah
Freddie asked me what's the difference
between shimmer and glitter you know the
difference between shimmer and glitter
and I didn't know there was a difference
I thought those are both adjectives
describing the same sparkles in like a
substance like so shimmer is a little
bit more low-key
shimmers like this a highlighter but
this is shimmery I was starting to go
cross-eyed like and then a glitter is
like you know a glitter it's like a
super over-the-top let's be clear I'm
not a beauty blogger understand let's
make sure like this you can I see what
brightened it up like a gold polish so
initially talking to Freddy I was really
intimidated because she was so specific
on what I needed but it was empowering
because once I left the conversation
with her I had almost a grocery list of
things to attack armed with Freddy's
list I felt good
next stop makeup store I was nervous I
was kind of shaking as I walked in but
just looking at the list looking up and
seeing something on the Shelf was like
ok I can do this I think I got what I
needed so I'm ready to go at this point
so being the type of guy that learns by
doing and having a bag full of makeup I
gave it a shot I put some on the brush
and we just kind of just go straight
back ok it didn't go bad it didn't look
good at all though so basically I got a
skunk I going right now doing it was
easy I can rub stuff on my face all day
but it looked terrible I don't know if
I'm doing this right it helped me in two
ways
I was more confident using the brushes
and I was I oh okay I get why people do
circular as opposed to blotting and I
started to understand why but in me
learning those skills it was looking
terrible on my face so after doing a
terrible job on myself I realized ok I
need to practice a lot and I need to
practice on somebody else so I reached
out to my co-worker Jada who did me a
solid favor by being my guinea pig and I
reached out to Freddy and together the
three of us tried it one more time ok so
doing it on Jada it it was better there
were certain things where I had to kind
of tag Freddy in multiple times when we
were
the blushing on the cheeks I had a
couple hard lines I didn't know what
hard lines was and apparently I was
doing that the entire time so I had to
fix that so it makes it kind of a bit
smooth yes as I was doing the eye shadow
that I used one of the buzzwords a
windshield wiping motion where it's when
you apply the eye shadow kind of in like
a rainbow formation thinking because I
had the buzzword and I seen it done I
was doing it right and Freddie kind of
had to tag and say no you're not doing
anything you got to kind of press it
again and then finally as I was doing
the lip gloss I had the most confident
because I was like oh it's it's lip
gloss he just applied that should be
easy and then I ended up jabbing Jada in
the lip even the things that I assumed
were easy it was still a little bit more
difficult doing it on somebody else and
just kind of getting the balance right
[Music]
up like this one has more color this one
is way more fun after doing a bad job on
myself and an okay job on Jada I felt
good but I still didn't feel confident
that was our test run
I think we look so cute for her first
time in LA out of the town it's gonna be
great okay so when she got here it was
Friday night it was time to go so I
brought her into my apartment I kind of
gave her the tour of my apartment and
almost on cue she was like so when are
we doing the makeover Kevin good times
come are you excited you ready to go
what we're doing today your makeup ready
for it I started with the blush I was
very excited because the blush that she
recommended was perfect because I looked
really good on Lynch skin and it really
brought out a lot of her those
undertones you see it's easy house a
little bit of color but it's not too
much color looks good after that I went
into the eyeshadow and there was a bit
of a snafu with the eyeshadow I set it
up on one side and then I kind of went
to the other side and as I was setting
it up on both sides I started to see
that her right eye was a little bit
chunkier I think she noticed it cuz she
looked here then she looked here and
then she came back again and when she
came back again I was like wait I think
she's measuring something so then I
stepped in front of the mirror to block
off what she can see and then that gave
me a window to fix it without her
noticing what was going on after I
applied the lip gloss I grabbed a little
bit of highlighter with a fan brush and
just kind of sparkled everything it felt
really completing when guys go to the
barber shop a lot of times we get the
brush on the back of our necks they take
the cape off and it's fit is finished
I enjoyed that satisfying feel of just a
little bit of brush a little glitter on
the cheeks and it was complete
transformation was complete and here we
are with the final look ready to go I
think that she was pretty she was pretty
happy with it how do you feel this how
did you like it in that moment I felt so
accomplished so proud and it wasn't
because I did anything it was because it
worked she liked it she was happy and it
that was that was my end-all intention
it was a little bit emotional because I
felt happy that I was able to kind of
share this moment with my daughter
growing up my dad was a
that so it was nice that I was able to
meet my daughter on something that she
was interested in something that got her
excited and we were able to share a
moment on her side of the fence because
I'm not seeing her as much as I used to
I wanted to show her that I'm willing to
go a little bit out of my comfort zone
to let her know that I still care about
her just as much as I did the first day
I met her right now
it was ridiculous I felt really weird I
looked terrible with makeup all over my
face but it was really nice because once
I connected with her in that moment we
were both happy and I think that it made
it all worth it
I'm ready to go are you ready to go yeah
but let's go watch the Lion King or
something you want to go hit the town
yeah let's hit the town alright peace
looking good so I got my daughter seal
of approval she liked it there's one
more person that I needed to show this
to alright I'm back with Freddie now
that the weekend is done we're all set
up I got to get a final reaction this is
the before here's the after oh my gosh
she was really pretty pretty approved
[Music]